foreign
let's go to Sammy in Billings Montana
what's up Sammy
call Dr Don how we doing
good thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for being available what's
up
yes uh well uh first uh I'm not the
native English speaker so I apologize in
advance I am a native English speaker
and nobody can understand me either so
we're in the same we're in the same boat
this morning
okay so um
uh I am a pathological liar
um and I don't believe you yeah just
kidding tell me about it
well uh
I don't know when like it exactly
developed but I mean it starts it's our
affecting my like job performance right
now and uh
uh I guess uh my family lies too and um
yeah so uh
I don't know how to uh
what do you lie about
well even the like smallest
insignificant thing like I lie about
them and sometimes I embellish events
and uh
yeah and uh I know but give me some give
me some examples what do you lie about
well
uh sometimes like uh I would be talking
to a friend and my wife would ask me
about what I was talking about and it's
like nothing significant but I tend to
lie about
that so uh um
things like this and uh
I guess last week I lied about some
something I did like I made a mistake on
my job like a really small mistake but
I didn't tell anyone and uh
uh
I guess uh they found out and
and it made it worse than it is yeah it
usually it usually does how long um
how long have you been in the states
uh so 10 years 10 years so I'm yeah so
I'm originally from the Middle East okay
and uh how old are you
uh 32. did you lie when you were 21
uh yes yeah so
I'm so um
back home uh I had a
a really like my dad was scary dude and
uh
I think he he
so maybe I think I started lying first
to him when he was like would ask me
about stuff when you say scary dude was
he abusive did he hurt you
uh
uh verbally okay uh physically is
not a lot but more like more probably
but some something some physical
uh not a lot I mean but some
yeah like I guess four or five times
okay
um yeah sorry go ahead let me let me
jump in here so
anytime we have
um some type of behavior that in a way
becomes automated or becomes a habit it
becomes a a default setting
I always want to and back out
and take a 30 000 foot view of of the
behavior and always want to ask one
overarching question
in for the last 150 years or so maybe a
little bit longer the questions we have
asked at that thirty thousand foot view
range from what happened to you when you
were a kid to what's wrong with your
brain chemistry to any number of of
questions the question I don't hear
asked very often that I'm trying to be
more assertive in changing the Public's
narrative and how we answer how we
approach some of these challenges and
this is where whether I'm I'm reaching
for junk food when I get stressed or
whether I reach for another drink when I
get frustrated or when I respond to a
text of somebody I'm not married to
because it makes my heart be a little
bit faster or if I just default to
telling the TR to lying all the time
the question I want us to ask is what is
my body trying to protect me from
because I'm convinced that all of the
all of the architecture of where some of
these challenge of where these
challenges distill in the brain and in
the body
Cascade out in a million different ways
physiologically and genetically all
these things are all over the place
but at the core is you have a body
that's trying to protect you
from what getting her hit when you were
a kid or getting screamed at when you're
a kid
um
getting left by your wife being judged
getting fired from your job and being
ashamed
what is what is your body trying to
protect you from Sammy
and in this and by the way this isn't
just in moments when you lie this is all
the time this little machine is running
underneath the surface
I guess being discovered
um what's what what's up what would
somebody find
I mean
logically speaking it's not anything bad
I mean relatively compared to yeah but
let's take logic out the window because
logically
not admitting to a small little issue at
work doesn't make sense and so logic
doesn't count here
be honest what is your body trying to
protect you from
can I throw some things out there that
might help
yes I bet you are and tell me if I'm
wrong
I bet you are profoundly and deeply
lonely
I bet your wife is one of the only if
not the only people that you can truly
count on and even that has a strange
hierarchy in the relationship to it
and your friends are kind of your
friends but they kind of work together
my guess is you've got stress about
money my great guess is you've got
stress about a whole family unit back
home telling you what you need to be
doing and how successful you need to be
am I onto the right track at all
yes
um
I uh
yeah I don't know I think I
I have two personalities like one that's
inside than the other is what I face the
world okay I'm I'm convinced that the
the core human need is this
when you distill everything down the
core human need is this
if people actually knew me would they
still love me
and here's my promise to you
um
let me back out there is no psychiatric
consensus so if you look at all of the
the literature there's no consensus on
pathological lying as a disorder they
even took it out of the last DSM-5 for
people who give a crap about that stupid
book they they it it's it's not even a
tangible concept if you will
it's floating around right and so we're
going to ask ourselves what is our body
trying to protect us from and you've
given me in just a few short minutes
you've given me some insights you come
from a really abusive home you're and
dropped into
Billings Montana as a kid who grew up in
the Middle East who's learning the
language in real time you're like trying
to change the oil on the car as you're
driving you have a job with a lot of
stress you've got a marriage you're
isolated you don't have your whole
Community with you all the time
and as you mentioned you've got an
inside guy inside your body that thinks
a certain way and talks a certain way
and has certain views on the world and
you have an external way you present
yourself Carl Rogers called that a lack
of congruence you have to bring the
outside the inside out
okay and so here's what that looks like
you have to find people that you can
trust
that you will say those inside things
out loud period
I'm terrified about fill in the blank
I hate fill in the blank
the politics of so and so makes me want
to vomit if I see another fill in the
blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank you have to be committed and if
you cheated on your wife you've got to
say it out loud
if you did some things in the Middle
East that you're not proud of and you're
here trying to recreate your life you've
got to speak them out loud you've got to
find people that you trust that might be
a therapist
that might be a religious Pastor a
religious leader that might be a couple
of close close friends but you have to
make that commitment and then when it
comes to lying I want you to change your
identity completely okay here's how we
do that
I want you to begin to repeat on a daily
basis
I am a man who only honors the truth
I'm a man who only speaks the truth I'm
a man who only says the truth and you're
going to have to practice being awkward
in those moments
so let's practice
it'll get better it will get better only
if you go all all in this is like
stopping drinking
if you're an alcoholic you can't limit
your drinks to Fridays and Saturdays
because you'll end up
hungover until Thursday and then you'll
start right back up again
this means that you're going to say
something your wife's gonna come in and
say who you're on the phone with and
you're going to say oh it's my dad but
actually it wasn't it was a friend from
work and you're gonna have to stop
yourself and say I just told you my dad
that wasn't true
it was my friend from work
your wife's gonna come in and say hey
where were you last night and you're
gonna say oh I had to work late and
you're gonna have to stop and go nope I
wasn't
I was out with some friends
I stayed late talking to this woman that
I kind of have an attraction to and we
probably need to talk about whatever the
thing is you screw something up at work
you're gonna stop what you're doing and
go find your immediate leader and
supervisor and say hey I just made this
small mistake here's how I'm correcting
it or here's how I've already corrected
it here's how I'm about to correct it
you're going to practice telling the
truth and when you tell it you're going
to feel so exposed and naked and
terrified I want you to feel that
absolutely feel that in your bones
and exhale
this is the the heading into that storm
I'm a guy who only tells the truth I'm a
guy who tells the truth I'm a guy who
tells the truth
and I will tell you Sammy I was a guy
that lied about everything to everyone
all the time
always
and then I changed my identity and now
I've become pathological about
truth-telling to the point that I have
to be careful because I can come across
as a jerk about it
but
there will only be telling the truth
from this point forward
your relationships aren't worth it your
mental health isn't worth it your
emotional health isn't worth it losing
your wife isn't worth it losing your
job's not worth it tell the truth bring
the inside guy out let the world meet
that guy
be fully you
be full of you